Wow.
We are in the land of the JavaScripters.
But you already knew that.
So, today, I'm going to share some thoughts
in a medium that you probably weren't expecting.
I know I'm not the first person to bring poetry
to a tech conference, and I sincerely hope
I'm not the last.
You see, JavaScript, and the people who write
JavaScript - that's you all - have been essential
to my work in developer relations.
I've watched the culture and the language
evolve and grow up over the past decade.
This is the tweet that went out announcing
my talk.
I was so excited and so honoured, I decided
to embrace it, even though I have never, ever
thought of myself as a golden girl.
I had to wonder: what would you all be expecting
from me?
So I struggled for weeks trying to find a
way into my story, and then one random Wednesday
morning in April, after several weeks of waking
up in the middle of the night in the dark,
in a cold panic, I decided to get up and write.
I began.
Why is my brain so unsharp?
This might be my last conference talk ever!
Then I kept going as the light crawled into
the garden, and the birds started making noise,
I wrote, ""The JS Confs were punk rock, they
cut the crap and went roller blading.""
Then I stepped slowly away from the display.
I grabbed a pad, a lined legal pad, and a
pen, and started writing.
14 lines later, it was a Sonnet, strict rhyme
scheme, a meter called iambic pentameter that
sounds like the beat of your heart.
I felt lighter than I had in weeks.
Writing poetry had put me into a fine state
of flow.
This is the first one, the beginning.
Here goes: when I consider JSConf EU and wonder
what it is I have to share, heroic JavaScripters
I once knew, or why UI or Ajax, or would you
even care?
I've studied coders long, but not the code.
I know constraint can free up self-expression.
Rhyme, scheme, metre, platform, network, Node,
but is there room on stage for true confession?
You see, I will speak of culture's evolution,
but you are the artisan of JS give and taking,
and I'm not here to 'splain your revolution,
it's iterative and comes from daily making,
creating more than apps and interactions,
you terraform immersive new distractions.
You're going to see this slide at the close
of every sonnet.
I will read nine of them, or eight more of
them today.
It's a visualisation of Lorenz's strange contractor,
a simplified model that describes con convex
know in the world's atmosphere, the unverified
idea of the butterfly effect that small changes
of state like a butterfly flapping her wings
can influence larger, more significant difference
s later and elsewhere, like triggering a Tornado
thousands of miles away.
We will get back to that a little bit later
in the talk.
For now, it turns out the constraints of poetry
are not totally different from the constraints
of code.
In producing things of craft, and artfulness,
in a sonnet, as in code, you have to pack
a lot of meaning and intent into tightly controlled
syntax and word choices.
And then there are elegant ways to go bonkers
and bend or break the rules.
Quick two-minute history of the sonnet form:
it was created in Italy in the early 13th
century, the poet Petrarch was its most famous
practitioner.
The form travelled across Europe and arrived
in England in the early 16th century, just
in time for the Liz - Elizabethan poets and
Shakespeare most famously of all who wrote
164 sonnets.
Through the centuries, poets everywhere wrote
sonnets in their own languages.
In Russia, in the early 1800s, Alexander Pushkin
wrote a novel in verse called Eugene Onegin,
about the life and times of a young romantic,
let's say.
In 1922, in German, in a chilly castle in
Switzerland, the Austrian poet Rheiner wrote
a 55-sonnet cycle called Sonnets to Orpheus.
In 1986, inspired by Pushkin, Indian-born
author Vikram Seth wrote Golden Gate.
He inspired me, and so it goes.
The sonnet endures as a poetic form for story-telling,
philosophying, celebrations of love and festive
occasions.
The second sonnet, the origin story, was inspired
by a talk from Jan Lenhardt written in 2015.
The times have changed with JavaScript's ascent.
Since Voodoo Tik.
God pitched us to sponsor a new event, a gathering
in Washington beyond the web 2.0 of suits
and swag, and paid product pitches, the first
JSConf happened in the spring, and almost
didn't due to funding givens.
But tickets sold.
It was a homecoming for folks who didn't know
that content plus fun could raise up a community
of like-minded coders where once was none.
It was not long to find an opportunity to
do another one in pulsing Berlin.
Jan, Malte, Kristina made the JSConfs and
considers considers Confs pure win.
In the sonnets ahead, I will continue to poke
at the relationship between the writer's craft
and the coder's.
In Elizabethan England, poets would release
their sonnets in private to an elite audience
before sharing them more widely, kind of like
I'm doing here today.
So, please be kind to these little songs of
mine.
Like me, they're travellers from an older
world.
Into JavaScript World Domination of course.
Trajectory is best viewed in retrospect.
A JS singularity was never inevitable.
But loose federation makes network effect,
and the JSConfs have been unforgettable.
Client side, server side, dark side of the
moon, Asia, Australia, Colombia, Budapest.
No JS and Tito launched from this cocoon,
Iceland, Scotland, CSSConfs and the rest.
It's that magic dynamic that comes to your
town, building cam lad which out of the fun.
Maybe it is conferences all the way down.
Artefacts of knowledge, with access for everyone.
And always new ideas are put in play, to globally
influence a generation's way.
One of those good ideas that did not emerge
immediately was the need for a code of conduct.
And a focused committed effort to enforce
it.
A along with a commitment to foster a diverse,
and inclusive environment for all attendees
and all speakers, we can and we must keep
doing better at this, and maybe this weekend,
I think this weekend has shown me some of
what's possible.
So, the code of conduct: at our events, we
do not tolerate harassment of participants
in any form.
A posted code of conduct works to mitigate.
In 2011, this was far from the norm.
Today, we raise each other up through schooling
for unbiased language and communication.
Appropriate kindness and respect, and tooling
to promote good behaviour and collaboration.
We will not tolerate at our events stalking
or following, or unwelcome comments.
This unwelcome contact, this includes offensive
verbal comments.
You see a code of conduct is a pact, reminding
each of us of our humanity, and hoping tolerance
can replace profanity.
Okay, in sonnet 5, I look back in time.
Emma Lazarus was a writer and activist in
New York City, well educated, and well to
do.
In 1883, she wrote the sonnet that eventually
found the plaque on the pedestal in the on
the Statue of Liberty in New York City Harbor.
Those are the words of welcome for immigrants
and refugees to the United States.
A digital immigrant, that's me, reflects on
em-La Lazarus: the sonnet is a poem of 14
lines, give me your tired, your poor, your
huddled masses.
Octave sestet define the sonnet of Shakespeare,
Petrach that made the Statue of Liberty ever
more a mother of exiles, for every refugee,
her lift ed lamp beside the golden door gives
worldwide welcome to the land of the free.
20 years to go from print to monument, written
in 1883, engraved on a plaque in 1903, a poem
for the immigrant, by an author and an activist.
A world-class harbour hack.
Emma, like me, a New York City girl with Jewish
roots, wielding words to change minds, our
work in cahoots.
T pause.
This next poem was inspired by a Ted talk
by Carole Cadwalladr whose role as a journalist
uncovered the work of Cambridge Analytica
in affecting the Brexit vote.
I will quote Zeldman where nothing fails like
success, about the dangers of surveillance
as a business model.
The immigrant who puts down roots but never
learns the language, that's JavaScript and
me.
Sometimes, code is export that changes lives
forever.
Though nothing fails like success to keep
us free.
Gathering wise words from Twitter, I could
read, I could Weave sonnets of bravery in
140 characters, gleaned from conferences recorded
to retrieve later, to remember the passion
of others.
Courage in the form of a Ted talk by Carole
Cadwalladr, to Silicon Valley, sheer terror
didn't stop her speaking truth to power.
Her urgency to save democracy.
Will we play with our phones as this darkness
falls?
Fascism rises when democracy palls.
I would not be here today if it weren't for
my employer, Mozilla, and I'm Not Really Sure
That the Web is It is It We Know It Were It
Not for Mozilla, So This is a Sonnet for Mozilla.
You may know Mozilla as the dinosaur that
birthed a browser open source out of Netscape's
ashes.
Long my Firefox endure as a user-centric client,
with a mission worth your love.
To protect the net as a global, public resource,
Mozilla makes browsers, apps, code, and tools
open and accessible, safe, and free.
A force for opportunity with level playing
field rules.
Keeping tabs on browser culture and internet
health, explicit in our aspirations, and stated
in our manifesto, in support of civil discourse,
collaboration and a wealth of user commitments.
Ten principles plus addendum show a clever
red panda that faints like a fossil.
Protecting web standards so the Open Web still
rocks.
I met Angus at a JS Conference in Brazil in
2015.
His book If Hemingway Wrote JavaScript, and
he spoke then about the connections between
language, literature, and JavaScript.
And I don't think that talk would ever have
happened without that book.
I also quote directly from some of Angus's
online writing about code poetry and code,
and when I do this, I want to indicate that
I'm quoting somebody else's words verbatim:
doctrine and dogma, these are the enemy of
good JavaScript, writes Angus Crall, a programmer
who codes English expressively.
If Hemingway wrote JavaScript, for whom would
it toll?
Crall's book praises pushing language boundaries.
For earnest, code works tersely and direct.
His simplicity conceals the quandaries of
eloquent reduction.
Jane Austin's code is circumspect.
If poetry is grace, if poetry connotes and
code commands, the choice of paths reveals
a human face.
An algorithmic style is still in human hands.
A 24-author pastiche goes beyond the charm
of ploy, and led me to write sonnets which
I hope will spark some joy - a-ha.
So thank you for indulging my book reviews,
and literary references that may be a little
unfamiliar.
They've given me a way to share some reflections
on culture and code.
You may have noticed also, that, in writing,
as in JavaScript, we are always borrowing
and building upon the writing and the work
of others.
Especially the texts or the libraries that
have shaped us, and taught us, and particularly
he will our fancy.
So there are several slides of reference links
and one more book review sonnet called Big
Data, Big Picture in the appendix, and also
on the JSConf EU sonnets page, which is live
now online if you really want to keep going,
I'm going to close with an homage to two programmes
which is close to my heart, one of Mozilla
text speakers, which I co-founded and led
for a few years, and maybe poised for world
domination like JavaScript, and Global Diversity
CFP Day, a young programme that came about
directly through the influence of JSConfs,
and that's been very present here this weekend.
So then: Mozilla Tech Speakers is a programme
designed, like Global Diversity CFP Day, to
make diverse speakers easier to find and share
skills, tools, and contacts along the way.
CFP day grassroots are self- sus - self-sustaining.
Mozilla's programme offers support and training
for web advocates and speakers from a host
of places.
These are living proof of working ecosystem,
stand alone programmes launched and thriving,
feeding global JavaScript momentum, nomadic
tribes of advocates arriving.
Is it the butterfly effect, or strange attractor?
The influence of JSConfs could well be a factor.
Today, IBA been speaking about the subtle
and intelligent things that are exchanged
when people come together with good intentions
and a certain spirit.
I've pushed past my own sheer terror to share
what I believe most deeply, that, if you can
be true to yourself, there are many amazing
and outrageously cool things you can do from
there.
Like organise a tech event in 60 cities on
the same day from an island in the far north,
or write Tennyson et cetera about JavaScript
in 21 days under pressure for a tech conference,
so, thank you so much to everyone who has
encouraged me on this journey, and thank you
all today so very, very much for your attention.
I'll be putting the slide deck up, and, like
I said, there are lots of resource slides,
and links, and one more sonnet in there.
Have fun.
If you're into John McCarthy and AI, you should
read that one!
Thank you all so much!
[Cheering and applause].